akash sings crowd work is some of the  best in the game and his new comedy  special shows why  hey why are you apologizing for laughing  bro look what we've done to white men  what he subtly does here is restates  what the crowd member says so now the  entire audience is in on the  conversation white men are like shelter  dogs now  he's apologizing for laughing at a  comedy show a lot of the times a comic  can get extra laughs just re-emphasizing  what has already been stated and then  giving a funny example of it it's like  watching reek and game of thrones  going through the whole arc you guys  used to run [ __ ] big dicks swinging  everywhere well moderate size dicks  swinging everywhere so the next time  you're doing crowd work try repeating  the audience members response and then  tagging it up with funny absurd examples  crowd work takes a lot of practice but  he is one of the best comics to study  because